Alex Trebek you know he has said over
and over again that he's not afraid of
dying but Alex struggles with leaving
his loved ones behind especially the
Saint who has stood by him through it
all what's the toughest part for both of
you I think for me it's when I see him
in pain and I can't help him
Jean Trebek is Alex's rock his soulmate
and the first person he told that he had
cancer he writes quote Jean doesn't
complain but I worry about the toll it
is taking on her I worry how it's
affecting our children Matthew and Emily
- they were so upset when I first told
them the diagnosis Alex writes it was a
tearful family meeting when he told them
his decision to not undergo
extraordinary measures to extend his
life but they accepted it tough to
explain it to them they handled it so
beautifully they understand that there
is a certain element regarding quality
of life and if the quality of life is
not there it's hard sometimes to push
and just say well I'm gonna keep going
even though I'm miserable Matthew and
Emily are now both adults Emily flips
houses in Los Angeles while Matthew owns
two restaurants in New York City he
returned home due to the Cova cut down
but alex says I know the real reason he
came he recognizes this is our last
go-round he's here to spend quality time
with me before we have no time left to
spend together
Alexson jeans love story began while she
was working as a friend's bookkeeper
despite their 24-year age difference
Alex was head-over-heels quote she was
the most charming person I had ever met
and she was drop-dead gorgeous he's just
my husband but I liked it better when
she would bow when I came into the house
in April of 1990 they said I do and Jean
became pregnant with Matthew just three
weeks after the wedding in his memoir
the answer is reflections on my life
alex says his kids would often visit the
Jeopardy set
Emily created this sign for Alex's
dressing-room door that reads in the
form of a question what is the world's
best dad
the Trebek's recently celebrated their
30th wedding anniversary spending it at
home with their kids a bottle of
champagne and Emily's homemade Paia Alex
writes this might be one of the
unintended positive consequences of
covin 19 it has brought our family
closer together I've lived a good full
life and I'm nearing the end of it
I know that the only thing that might
bother me is if I pass on before I get
to have grandchildren in him just a
little bit of pressure on his kids can
we go back to Alex's other love jeopardy
he's often asked who he wants to replace
him he jokingly said in his book Betty
White because the audience wants someone
quote younger and funnier
[Music]